Hãy bố in điểm khi đầu tư vì LASTA, Thuy Nguyên. Thì chương bất động sản hay phòng đang
dịch truyền mạnh về thuy Nguyên, nơi khi phải thành trưng cấp thành chính, công nghiệp
lồ Thuy Nguyên. Chó sâu cắt dự án hiện hiểu, vì LASTA, Thuy Nguyên nổi bật với những lợi
tế nhà đầu tư liên cân nhắc. Một, khả năng lấp đầy. Thuy Nguyên hội tụ lạc
khu công việc lớn, VC, Nam Cầu Kuyên, Chẳng Sự, Thủ Hú Chương Già, Kí Sự,
là động chẻ về sinh sống. Nguyên cầu ăn tư và thuy ở tư tế tăng nhên, đảm mảo tình đất đầy
uống định cho khu đồ thiệt.
2. Tiếng Nam Cuyên Xoang, Nhà Phê V LASTA, Thuy Nguyên nằm tại lỗi thuyên Xoên,
sát chực chính và khu cao tần thận lợi mồ cụ hàng, xôi luôn, văn phòng.
Một khác đến từ cả cư dân lội tụ lẫn thách vãng lại giúp kiện thái thách
kinh dân bình bữ. 3. Lợi thế giúp vụ.
Cộng đồng cư dân chè, chân ra hình thành sẽ kéo theo nguy cầu cao về dịch buộc,
3. Trăm sóc xúc quay, giáo dục, ẩm thực, đây là thị trường kiếm năng cho các mua hình dịch buộc
ra chị ra tăng.
4. Giá chị tích sẵn.
Sột đỏ xử lâu dài, quên và trường chình,
thả tân thành hiểu trong 20 đến 20 của trang 20 đồng rặt hoàn thiệt,
cầu Nguyên trái, cầu lại sôn, cầu dính, đây lộ 3. Năm xí xe.
Đây là tài sản vừa khai thách được vừa tích sản dài hạn với dựa tăng ra đáng tì.
Dựa an của ra mắt thân thư phía quý,
sở hiểu vị thế thử sôn, vốn thuy,
cùng hạt tầm đồng bộ, nhiều mạng xanh và hệ thống thích ít nội thuộc,
thuộc quy đồng phía hệ quay 3 giọng sình tầm đáp ứng đa giọng nguy cầu.
Dòng cân đang ăn ai bối thông dưới bẩy miếm mê phuông,
khai thách linh hoạt theo vụ cầu.
Dòng cân nhà vườn sức ngày trở không tảm ư đệm chim miếm mê phuông,
khi trước khu sa sấm ốt, kia sau là công viên dộ hơn 1.5.
Dòng cân thư phố bà ra hồn lời hơn chim miếm mê phuông,
lựa thế mặt diền lời lên đến 2.5 mất,
tự lợi cho hỏa đồng kinh xanh.
Như vậy, bối bộ ít điểm này,
viên lất ta, khi miên không chỉ là nơi ăn thư,
mặt con là trọng độ tư ăn quán.
Có khả năng tạo dòng biên và ra tăng ra chị thách chùi phát triển của chúng tâm mối hệ phòng.